do your parents ever give you any
concerns about some of the safety in
your videos or no no I think they're
used to it I mean I've almost I almost
burned my parents house down once
specifically that was bad what is it
with science YouTube isn't awesome
I was just like you know doing like the
aerosol flamethrower but I used uh
carburetor cleaner
oh my God which is like its own solvent
but it's like an aerosol with a solvent
and so it's like oh my and so what you
did in like the living room it just went
straight up in the garage and it like
something in the ceiling caught on fire
is this just a riot passage to every
science or engineering yeah you must
have like almost blown up or set your
house on fire yeah
[Applause]
I didn't know how to go to that
transition I kind of I kind of realized
that I said
if there's one video on your channel I
have seen it's that one I cannot believe
somebody took it from me that was my job
oh you wanted to be the one who did it
yeah were the insurance fraud and
everything did you get it exactly I mean
if you think about it though like that's
what everybody else thought they're like
oh you burned your house down I'm like
people actually think that I'm not
anymore but there was dude there was
I've never experienced anything yeah
you're watching in the hate video about
how obviously people's donated to the
GoFundMe and that was really stressful
because people felt like you owed people
yeah yeah like what like what was going
through your head with all of that stuff
like it just seemed like I mean I I
don't even know how I would begin to
process if that happened to me I think
that like I do pretty well in like high
stress situations where it kind of just
goes like full logic brain
um and in that situation it's like okay
just move forward move forward move
forward so it's like what is the most
reasonable thing to do right now yeah
and at the time it was just get
everything organized continue to post
videos
um try to you know find a new place to
live but like I think we ended up living
in the motorhome for like eight months
we should have did an RV room yeah in an
RV in my parents driveway if my house
button down posting videos would be the
last yeah yeah honestly it was it was
like the only thing I had though yeah I
had lost everything like all my tools
like I I saved my computer but I never
set it up because I didn't have anywhere
to put it up so like because I mean
obviously I saw the video but like I
don't know what was happening like did
you like did you have insurance for your
place or it's like did you get did you
get we had got renters insurance three
months before
wow
and that actually like saved our asses
because the day of you we immediately
went to uh cash like a three thousand
dollar check for the from the renters
yeah right because otherwise it was like
we didn't have any money yeah
did you know because obviously having I
imagine that like losing a lot of your
possessions and stuff like that that's
got to change how you like view
everything yeah like like how does it
shift how you feel about
um I think it was like a forced
exploration where it was like okay I
can't do what I've been doing yeah so I
have to figure out a way to keep doing
stuff and try to be entertaining and
nice
my ADHD just went go for it and it was
also weird too because I had spent a
bunch of time kind of just I don't know
how to describe it but like you know you
said you're like watching anime this is
a hobby like when I built the laser
cutter that kind of was the big start of
my channel like I had built that as a
hobby like I was saying like oh maybe I
could make some money with it maybe I
can make parts for people but like I
wanted that for me because the guy that
used to have one near me moved and so
once the house burned down I was so
focused on just making videos that like
I felt like I didn't have any time to
kind of like re-establish anything like
making a new laser cutter or building a
workshop it was just kind of like video
video video video video right and so it
was a very kind of like a realization
that I need to definitely like figure
out how to separate myself from making
videos so that I can do other stuff to
kind of almost build up what you would
actually use in your day-to-day life to
make the videos if that makes any sense
at all yeah yeah
I mean like I I can sympathize with what
you go through but I don't even know
what I how I would act yeah yeah I
wouldn't be able to think of anything
yeah I never lost it my brain my brain
would just shut down yeah yeah yeah
yeah I don't know I have no idea how I
mean we had you know like the GoFundMe
was a huge safety net like we actually
ended up like I didn't pull the money
out of there for a long time we were
sort of still living yeah because I
didn't know what to do I genuinely did
not know what to do I did not know if I
was gonna get like screwed on taxes or
it's gonna be like conflicting like
should I yeah use it and I never add
anything like I think you know the most
money I'd ever had in my account was
working entirely through college I think
I saved it like fifteen thousand dollars
yeah and then over the couple years
after college basically got down to like
nothing and Chelsea had the only jobs
like I wasn't working she was paying
rent I had like nothing yeah and so all
of a sudden it's like I don't I don't
know I don't know what to do like I
don't I literally don't know normally I
buy groceries and pay gas yeah with my
money that I make I've never had an
opportunity to figure something else out
yeah and you mentioned in the video
you're like you felt bad that you'd like
uh have a Tesla or something
um yeah I mean there was a joke in one
of the early videos where like we did
like a special effects of like a
cardboard cutout of a Tesla yeah yeah I
feel like a lot of YouTubers feel like
that they're like I don't wanna I don't
want people to like think I have money
yeah right and I must be like Amplified
even more so when people give you that
money people would say really bad things
for a while and it just sort of helped
to like feed into the people said stuff
immediately like we a guy that we're
still friends with uh that used to work
at Disney invited us to come work at
Disney or to come to Disney it's like
totally like out of the blue like that's
right yeah he's like I work at Disney I
can get you in for free so we went and
visited and he got it he used his family
passes to get us in and posted a picture
on Instagram and it's like of course
some of the comments everybody yeah oh I
see you're spending the money well
already it's like oh my God
I had money existed before before the
money you guys gave me I can spend my
money but you didn't keep all your money
under your mattress you know you have a
bank account for a reason and it's like
I would love to do more stuff and like
we've been trying to do more stuff with
money because I think it's fun to like
expand and I think a lot of people don't
understand that running a YouTube
channel like there's two parts of it
you've got kind of the art side of it
and you've got the business side of it
absolutely like there's people that work
for me yeah yeah like I've had people
working for me for the past like you
know four years like I have to pay them
yeah yeah
absolutely a lot of people forget that
now it's like if you see some big
YouTubers they probably have a team
behind them yes and like I've gone out
of my way like we we've tried as hard as
we can so like anybody that works for us
has like health insurance yeah like
there's places that's that's a big thing
in the US yeah especially when they work
for you exactly they need to like double
up on health insurance so we figured out
how to like uh you know we have a small
company that does brand deals for a lot
of science channels and everybody that
works there is health insurance and like
I don't pay for that directly it just
sort of runs itself right um but that
has sort of been like a blessing for
everybody yeah because it kind of helps
to like unify us a little bit so people
can't screw us over
um and we're doing you know a bunch of
merchandising stuff now and I have uh my
friend Ian who's working on the Channel
full time and it's like these are all
people that are working full-time you
have to pay them it's like you gotta
absolutely and you're in California and
it's in California
it can be frustrating sometimes when
people say stuff like oh like you know
three thousand dollars a month and it's
like oh my God if you could hire
somebody for 3000 like you know how much
money it costs to hire somebody in
California you make three thousand
dollars a month aren't you just maybe
getting by I don't know the medium
that's not great in California I don't
know
is that possible you could you could do
it yeah but you'd be like an apartment
with roommates and stuff right right
it's like it's it's in a lot of places
that would be a lull yeah but in LA and
California that is nuts no especially if
your company's not paying you health
insurance or anything do you need to pay
for that on your own or if you're like a
contractor freelance like I work for
myself and it's like oh yeah then you
gotta pay self-employment tax and you
gotta get yourself health insurance
you're from California right right yeah
so you've just been in California a
whole lot there's no party that's like
yeah just get a giant piece of land and
you think about it all the time yeah I
promise like my family lives there like
what am I supposed to do that's true
move your family over as well I mean I
live here my family certainly is not
from here yeah
how can you see them now I mean do you
want to see them I do I do I have you
seen that um I'm sure you watch a curse
cassettes yes did you watch the video
where they talk about the how often like
how much you'll have seen your family
and in like your entire life oh yeah
maybe instant depression really I
immediately texted my mom
in this video they basically explained
that like by age 18 you will have spent
like 90 of your of the time with your
family that you will ever yeah it makes
a lot of sense and that's like that was
such a sobering and depressing thought
but it's true yeah yeah it made me want
to really try more but also I the being
on the other side of the world uh makes
it a lot harder what's that flight yeah
it kind of just cries a single tear
while living in Japan thousand like
halfway across the world from Islam I
was just like I did I was like Mom I
love you it's great you're an amazing
parent you're so good but well I Skype
them all the time yeah yeah so I feel
like that's better than some like I call
my parents at least like two three times
a week that's good that's right I think
that's true yeah that's quite a long
compared to what I ask other people
that's because they want to I don't know
why they just want to call me up and
talk to me about random [ __ ] I don't
know did they like the YouTube stuff oh
yeah they they've really gotten into it
recently yeah the first three four years
they were like we don't get it
um and then ever since trash taste
um and oh you make money now we get it
yeah well the ever since they kind of
saw like 10 bucks they were excited yeah
they thought that was really the same
with Maya yeah they were like wait so
you just made 10 bucks from posting a
video from doing that cringe thing you
do in your room yeah
they were always really supportive but
they didn't really like get it yeah and
then ever since I kind of made my
content more focused around just doing
kind of more showing off kind of bizarre
side of the Japan where which anyone can
watch you can any any age group you can
watch this and understand what's
happening uh they watch it a lot more
and they they actively tell me about my
videos now yeah which is kind of good
and bad yeah yeah yeah
my parents watch Trash taste every week
I don't know how they do it God's
parents are gonna know who you are yeah
yeah exactly exactly like it was so
weird [ __ ] going back home this uh
these last few months and then like
Friday would come around yeah like come
downstairs I'm like why do I hear my
voice
and they would be watching trash teeth
Dad I'm right here if you want to talk
to me talk to me in real life
do they not watch your videos my mom
does
my dad my dad's my dad
my mom is like a fan though yeah yeah my
mom is what's that Meme of like if
William has a million fans I'm one of
them yeah 100
000 fans that's my mom I'm there in the
front row
that makes sense that's so cute that's
very funny I mean like at this point
because we live halfway across the world
my parents use YouTube as a way to keep
up what I'm doing yeah they're like did
trash taste upload this weekend okay my
son's alive yeah yeah it's so weird like
whenever whenever I call my parents and
then they bring up something I'm just
like how do you know I don't remember
ever talking to you about that and then
they're like oh yeah we saw it on trash
dance I was just like oh my God I'm
sharing too much oh my God it happens
all the time like even like like people
who you sort of casually know or don't
know leave a comment about something and
you're like where did I say they're like
oh my God I guess like oh my God what am
I talking about
like oh people listen to that I don't
know do your parents watch safety third
at all what do you think I don't think
so your mom has watched a few years I've
taught her how to like listen to it in
the background okay that's better yeah
definitely
yeah because like I think there was
there was like me before trash Chase and
then everything I've said after trash
days my pet I sometimes I'd say a story
or something in my childhood my parents
be like you [ __ ] why do why
didn't you tell us this we're talking
[ __ ] about us on your podcast my dad's
done that to me so many times where he's
just like yeah that thing you said like
four episodes ago you're so full of [ __ ]
and obviously yeah
I said something in a video where I was
like I made a joke about my childhood
that was like sarcastic you know like I
don't remember what it was my mom was
like that's not true like almost like
like I was like Mom yeah I'm like no no
it's just a joke I don't I don't think
most people think it's yeah I think oh
sorry oh man yeah I I think especially
YouTube videos are much more fun because
you can control it but trash taste and
podcasts in general you spew so much
things that you don't even remember
saying I don't know what I said yeah
I've said so much stuff yeah yeah it's
just they just come out the words just
come out oh you have to you can't do
this for like 100 episodes no I don't
remember half the [ __ ] I said in this
episode yeah to be honest
you were talking about weird stuff
I probably yeah I'm not even surprised
that's only 30 minutes every time I open
my mouth it just cut to that camera